uh good afternoon everybody Tim thank
you very much for that introduction
it's a delight to be here and really an
honor to even be asked I I want to thank
you all for coming and staying to the
end uh I I want to get right to my
presentation because it's it's important
for me to hear what you have to say
about the economy what questions you
have my wife tells me I have two
problems one problem is I don't listen
to people
and the other problem I don't remember
what I can't remember what she said
there was another problem I see you
didn't think I'd be funny did you you
thought this is going to be on the
economy all right all right since this
is a Hillsdale event I'm going to
discuss the Biden economy economy much
as I would in a college Economist
classroom this will be a shorter
Reader's Digest version of a few
lectures but but I'll attempt to present
facts interspersed with some political
commentary uh mostly because my wife
says I can't help myself so there's
going to be political comedy maybe that
was the second thing she said all right
I'm going to cover four topics on the
Biden economy the first is where we are
second is why does this feel so much
worse than we're being told it is third
how did we get here
and fourth is there anything President
Biden can do at this point so first
where are we
well I'm going to tell you something
that just about everybody on Wall Street
knows despite what you read in the
financial press
the Biden administration's economic
policies are driving us into a
recessionary ditch now this is what
happens when a president's economic
policies are designed to accomplish
leftist political goals such as
advancing radical radical climate agenda
or increasing government dependence
rather than growing the economy and
creating Prosperity let's see if I can
run this thing
apparently not there we go
in a recent Wall Street Journal survey
of 23 large financial institutions that
do business directly with the Federal
Reserve two-thirds predicted a U.S
recession in 2023 two more predicted a
recession in 2024 only five
predicted that we would avoid a
recession in 2022 2023 and 2024 and even
they only predicted we'd have a half a
percent in economic growth in GDP growth
which is you know it is way below the
2.1 percent average over the last 20
years but is also dangerously close to
what traditionally was considered a
recession which was two quarters of
negative economic growth that is until
the financial press changed that before
the midterm so that President Biden
would look good after we had two
quarters of negative economic growth
in any event for the American people
this all means stagnant declining
standards of living fewer job
opportunities lower wages and increased
poverty then that's kind of a cool side
the people that do my slides for me they
think they're very artistic I told them
it was an economic lecture in any event
and it will mean increased poverty
overall a far less less vibrant and far
less prosperous society and this is
where we are this is we're on the verge
of a very serious recession
all right second why does it feel
so much worse that we're being told why
does it actually feel like we're on the
verge of a recession even though we're
being told that we're not
well our current economic situation is
particularly disheartening as it comes
on the heels of the Trump era
which once again proved
once again opened our eyes to true
American potential when we have low
taxes reduced regulation and a bountiful
supply of domestic energy
now everybody particularly minority and
low-wage earners reap the benefits of
the Trump economy you may recall there
were abundant job opportunities
increasing wages historic highs in
family income historic lows in the
poverty rate and the unemployment rate a
growing labor force it's now shrinking
and declining income inequality all
without inflation
now let's look at a couple of those
metrics just to see how good things were
back in the back in the day let's look
at median family income
and poverty let's start with median
family income it grew in 2019 which is
the last year before the pandemic it
grew in nearly 73 thousand dollars that
was not only a 6.4 percent increase over
but it was also the largest yearly
increase going back to 1967.
it was 45 percent more growth in one
year
than the Obama at Biden Administration
achieved in eight years
there was in under Trump
median family income group four thousand
six hundred dollars in one year
under Obama and Biden it grew three
thousand two hundred dollars in eight
years
now contrary to what you may have heard
the economic benefits of this increased
family income were really widespread
this wasn't something where just rich
people were getting richer every racial
group benefited blacks Hispanics Asians
and white Americans all hit new record
highs new record high income levels
while median family increase income
increased for whites 5.7 percent
remember it increased 6.4 on average so
whites were below the average at 5.7 it
grew 7.9 percent for blacks 7.1 percent
for Hispanic Americans and 10.6 for
Asian Americans
and as for those Democratic talking
points about how the Trump tax cuts
benefited only the rich well they were
false as incomes grew in 2019 the
poverty rate plummeted 1.3 percentage
point to a new 60-year low of 10.5
percent this chart goes back to 1959 and
as you can see just to the left of the
11.6 which is the most recent poverty
rate under Biden you can see that dipped
down to the 10 percent line by 10.5
percent uh that was the low poverty rate
uh it's low historical poverty rate
which occurred under President Trump
it's the lowest it's ever been since the
since the government started reporting a
poverty rate this lifted 4.1 million
people out of poverty
and just for comparison purposes
under Obama and Biden the number of
people living in poverty decreased
or increased not decreased but increased
000 people during the eight years that
they were in office so 4.1 million
people
decrease in poverty under Trump an 800
000 person increase in eight years with
Obama and Biden so where is the poverty
rate today as you can see it's at 11.6
percent it's bounced back up despite all
of the government largesse during the
pandemic
and again the decrease in poverty
under Trump disproportionately favored
blacks Hispanics and Asians while the
poverty rate for whites decreased eight
tenths of a percent again below the 1.3
percentage point average for blacks it
fell two percentage points Hispanics 1.8
and Asians 2.8
look 2019 should be remembered as the
year of the worker and that progress
didn't come from mandated wage increases
empowered unions racial reparations
oppressive climate regulation tax
increases or any other misguided
government efforts to redistribute
wealth and impose economic equality
rather working-class Americans of all
colors saw their circumstances
materially improve in 2019 because of
economic freedom justice occurred in the
1980s under President Reagan this is
probably the only group I could ask this
question to and I might have a few
people raise their hands but was any
were any of you present in 1977 when
Ronald Reagan gave his whatever happened
to free enterprise speech at Hillsdale
College at the Von miser's lecture
nobody I tell you if you have if you
haven't heard that speech oh we have
somebody all right if you if you weren't
there you haven't heard it pull it up on
the internet and read it you'll much of
what I'm going to say today is inspired
by what's in that speech and it was an
incredible incredible economic speech
but today to get back to reality our
prospects are dimming primarily due to a
decline in economic freedom driving
rampant inflation
since March of 2021 the Consumer Price
Index that's the average change in
prices paid by consumers for goods and
services has surged
as we all know inflation is dramatically
increasing and this is what this chart
shows now this chart isn't percentage
increases this is the actual dollars
that they base the percentages on so
when Biden's out there saying you know
inflation's coming down inflation's
coming well it's not coming down it
keeps going up and the reason for that
is that it's just increasing at a
somewhat slower rate the FED looks for
inflation to be about two percent we're
now at 6.4 percent and of course under
Biden at one point it hit nine percent
so it is better than it would the worst
month under Biden but it's still not
coming down and you can see when you
break out on the right hand side we we
broke out what's happened with the
Consumer Price Index or inflation uh
under Biden and it's a it's a horrific
Story the chart on the left goes back to
1947.
now you can see what's happened this is
a phenomenal and phenomenal and
important increase now the FED has to
take some credit for this going up they
didn't react in a timely manner when
inflation started to set in
remember they called it transitory you
know I looked transitory to you anyway
they called it transitory but since last
year they have been taking action
increasing interest rates at really the
fastest Pace since the 1980s now looking
at this you might think that jump that
bump is the 1980s this but this chart
only goes back to 2013. that bump is the
Trump Administration when there was
virtually no inflation it was about two
percent it was right at the fed's
average but with a republican in office
they decided that they needed to raise
interest rates and fight all this
incredible economic growth we were
experiencing
you can see that before Trump took
office there was no increase in interest
rates those were the Biden years and
then it went down to really zero
during the pandemic and then stayed at
zero until they couldn't ignore
inflation anymore and the red line is
the increase uh since since last year
under President Biden now according to
the minutes of the fed's December
meeting so just a couple months ago it
intends to continue raising rates
because inflation's proven quote more
persistent and widespread than
previously anticipated I guess what's
when they were anticipating would be
transitory that's according to Jerome
Powell now no matter what you're hearing
in the Press
the recession That Wall Street financial
institutions are forecasting the one
they told the Wall Street Journal they
thought was coming is inevitable If the
Fed has to continue increasing interest
rates and in fact this morning uh the
FED came out and said they're going to
continue increasing interest rates
because they need to get this inflation
inflation under control so how did this
happen
but after the great Trump economy years
all we needed to do
to create Dynamic economic growth was
get back to the policies we had in place
and watch the economy boom
now I wrote two pamphlets during the
pandemic they they call them broadsider
from a con encounter books
and they say they said exactly that one
was entitled getting America back to
work that was in I think June or July of
2020 and the second one a few months
later was it's time to let America get
back to work because I was getting
frustrated
but that obviously didn't happen America
didn't get back to work we didn't have
those kinds of economic policies and why
is that well coming out of the pandemic
we really knew two things
first we knew people had a lot of money
you know which would drive the demand
for goods demand for goods would go way
up
personal savings from 1959 to 1920 or
through 2021 are on this chart and you
can see going back to 1959 the savings
rate for Americans
the savings rate for Americans was was
pretty level
and then during the pandemic obviously
it it surged it was unprecedented
you know by the way keep in mind the
left-hand side of this chart because I'm
going to show you a more updated chart
shortly and I want you to keep in mind
just how consistent the savings rate was
going back to 1959.
but this chart shows you've got this
huge surge Now The Surge wasn't a
mystery the federal government handed
out five trillion dollars during the
pandemic and people really had very few
places to spend all this money they
really couldn't go out nobody wanted to
travel nobody wanted to go to
restaurants nobody wanted to go shopping
everybody was kind of staying home
because they didn't want to get the
virus
so by early 2021 and that's where this
chart ends early 2021
you can see the savings rate is
significantly higher than it has ever
been
so you knew people had a bunch of money
demand was going to be high people had
cash what did we what else did we know
well second we knew fewer people were
working
back
there we go we knew fewer people were
working
and really if you tried to do anything
around your house back then you knew
that right first of all you couldn't get
anybody to come do anything and then if
they wanted to come do something and
they had to buy a you know a new sink or
something to put in for you that nobody
was making sinks you couldn't get
anything
people were unable to work businesses
were unable to anticipate future demand
and so there were a lot fewer people
employed a lot fewer people working so
obviously when Biden took office in new
two things people had a lot of money
which was going to drive demand
and the supply of goods was going to be
low because really you can't make a good
you can't deliver Goods if you don't
have people working so you knew demand
would be high and Supply would be low
now as we all know
inflation is a result of demand
exceeding Supply even if think the Trump
years when demand was high and Supply
was high we didn't have inflation
because there wasn't there were enough
Goods to meet the demand so prices
didn't surge up
but when demand exceeds Supply as it
obviously was going to you knew you knew
you were going to have an inflationary
surge
well what what would you do if you were
coming in as president you knew not
enough people were working so you had
Supply problems you knew people had a
lot of money
so you're going to have increased demand
what would you do
well I'll tell you what you wouldn't do
you wouldn't give people more money
juicing demand
through welfare programs that discourage
work thereby further reducing Supply
you know that that seems it seems simple
enough but but Democrats didn't get it
see Democrats thought and and Biden in
his uh economic team in particular
they really they could have they really
could have just sat back
and with Trump's 2019 policies in place
watch the market correct itself
and that they could have taken credit
for the rebound